like that's a very addict thing like i
need to get with
the most dramatic woman you know i need
to be
where the action is happening and that's
exciting and it's intoxicating and it's
ultimately a distraction for whatever
emotional issues you're having because
you don't have to
sit with yourself and deal with yourself
the next must-watch of the summer which
is road runner the new bourdain
documentary
that thing is rife with so much
archival footage it was shocking just
how much
of anthony bourdain's trajectory
was captured on film because the
documentary tracks his arc
from the early days when it he was the
chef at
lazal leia i think that's how you say it
all the way through all of his successes
and ultimately his demise and
i love the documentary jeff gordoner
invited me to a press screening when i
was in new york city
the week before it came out it's now out
in theaters now i don't think it's
streaming
but i'm sure it will be soon um i was
very moved by this i mean
i would suspect like you anthony
bourdain you know holds uh holds a large
place in my
in my consciousness his passing was was
was a tough one i think for all of us um
and i don't quite know what it is
about him but he was able to connect
with so many people in such a
profound meaningful way and i think the
documentary does a really good job
of of helping you understand who this
guy was and
and what made him tick you have not had
a chance to see this i have not seen it
yet
um because it's not streaming and i only
stay
at home you're here now oh wait
i i got outside a little bit uh i go
home or to the beach rich that's right
right you've never met anthony bourdain
i've never met him no
no i never met him but you know as us
lonely planet riders
like we're like the road warrior hacks
yeah of yore
um going to places that he that he's
gone to with his crew and
and eating some of you know in these
similar restaurants and
and finding that like ethnic food that
that nobody see you know
that jonathan gold here in la and the
anthony bourdain
overseas aesthetic is it figures
prominently in
almost all lonely planet writers i mean
that's what
that's what we aspired to and did in our
own way
and expressed in our own way so very
kindred spirit stuff there and
um and obviously the the work itself is
great and then he's got the
kind of somewhat taoist uh you know
eastern
philosophy that that uh that he's
appropriated is the wrong word but that
he's because he actually
cared about it and studied it and and um
and so i can relate to that
um and so uh you know definitely when he
died it was it
you know it was shocking to be honest
with you and and
um and and sad uh but someone i always
have admired and and
continue to admire and i'll watch
anything with him in it so
i'm really looking forward to this yeah
just utterly compelling to watch him
a captivating charismatic personality
who had this expansive joy
um for experiences of all kinds and
irrespective of however successful he
became was really just
like one of us like he was in every man
and he was much more interested in
having a conversation with a random guy
in the street than he was about
going to some velvet rope of that yeah
and i think what's interesting about him
and and the documentary of firms like
this take that i've always had
which is that this guy essentially was
an untreated alcoholic
i mean i i'm convinced that this was the
case big drinker
so he had this heroin problem he kicked
heroin
he kicked hard drugs as far but without
without going to narcotics
but but he's this extreme personality
and
that ism inside of him divorced itself
from
hardcore substances but remained
active and would latch on to anything
and everything
that could kind of take him out of
whatever emotional
disaffection he was experiencing and
that extremism made him
this larger-than-life personality but
so it was in many ways his strength and
and what endeared
us all of us to him so so profoundly but
also ultimately you know paved the way
for for his demise
i mean he continued to drink and you
know smoke pot and stuff like that so it
wasn't like he actually got sober
but you see over the course of this
documentary
how he latches on to certain um
not not not just substances but people
experiences like he goes from you know
being just
the guy who just smokes like crazy to
being an insane jiu jitsu
practitioner and that becomes his
obsession
um a healthier obsession of course than
some of his other ones
travel experiences that obviously
underscore
you know why those television shows that
that he did
you know impacted so many people but
you know a brooding dark guy who was an
incredible writer
and an incredible friend like thinker
thinker
the person who would really invest a lot
of time into his friendships and
really was curious about what made other
people tick
and you know really appreciated
his friends i think in a way that we can
all learn from
but i think ultimately where it all
really begins to unravel
is when he gets involved with aj argento
near the end and
she becomes his obsession and he remarks
early in that relationship
a self-awareness that this potentially
could be his demise
and the documentary i won't spoil it but
it kind of plays this out and you
you see how everything starts to line up
for him to realize that it meet his
fateful land
was he an escapist because i i think
about escapism a lot because i think i
have that in me
well escape i think escapism can mean
different things i mean i look at it
as i always say through the lens of of
of recovery and addiction and i just see
somebody who was an untreated addict and
and had
a profound whether it's a hole in your
spirit or
um an inability to just sit with
yourself that drove a lot of those wild
experiences
and and you know compelled him to go to
places other people wouldn't go
you know like beirut when it's you know
being bombed and places like that
that's part of like that's a very addict
thing like i need to be where the action
is i need to get with
the most dramatic woman you know i need
to be
where the action is happening and that's
exciting and it's intoxicating and it's
ultimately a distraction for whatever
emotional issues you're having
because you don't have to sit with
yourself and deal with yourself
and you see the pain and the tension
between
that pull that drive inside of him and
the fact that
he has a wife and he has a kid and the
um the uh
what's the right word for it the kind of
um
he tortures himself over his over his
relationship with child in that you know
he he's not sure he's being a good dad
and he so desperately wants to be a good
dad
and yet you know he has this huge life
that all of us look at and say
i would be happy if i had that life and
you realize that
that life is disconnected from whether
or not you know you're going to be happy
because that's some that's a that's the
relationship between you and you and has
nothing
to do with the externalities that are
swirling around that guy
or any of us you know having lived on
the road for eight months a year for
seven eight years is a lonely planet
author um
eight nine months and you're chasing
like cool destinations and going weirder
and weirder places
that we call i call it weirder we're
more unusual
places it's a better way of putting it
um
to get further and further away from the
known world
or our own culture and our own selves um
you know a lot of people called that the
dream job
um most people wouldn't last one year
doing that uh you know to last seven or
eight years was a lot for me
there's people out there still doing it
that i know although the pandemic has
halted a lot of those contracts but
um most people would not last one year
and if you
when you you know the new york times had
the 52 places journalists and
all of them a lot of them have written
about it afterwards and a lot of them
were i mean that so far i think they
were pretty exhausted by the end
and uh wouldn't necessarily recommend it
as a great lifestyle
like a lonely planet lonely writer well
it's like jeff gordoner said about like
needing a healthier lifestyle after
years of eating and being a great food
critic and you know
um he he taps into some of that same
stuff it's different than that because
we're not getting
that same but you do get some of those
meals you know so you do have
you do have a little bit because we're
writing about food but we're also
staying in crappy places and nice places
you know we're on the
ferries we're on the rickety airplanes
you read about you know
i can't tell you how many indonesia
flights i took and
after every trip to indonesia because
indonesia has a very bad air safety
record you could look it up it's not
good at all
and after every trip over there when
i've done you know 30 domestic flights
i'm happy that i mean
you know like like that kind of stuff
but that's part of the appeal too
but in the end you're you know um there
is an element like i want to do that
i love my the fact i live in a small
place in la and i can open the door and
the doors to the whole world
um but you do lose track you know you it
my
my situation came with a failed marriage
it came with missing lots of weddings
and
of friends it came with missing
birthdays and and holidays
um and you know i couldn't imagine doing
that with
with zuma at home now sure so yeah
you're also not an addict
you know what i mean imagine the guy
who's like oh my god i'm gonna get on
this plane and it might crash
like let's get in it you know right
that's the difference right right
[Music]
you